[Musique]
alors on pourrait penser que nos villes
sont conçues par les architectes par les
urbanistes pourquoi pas parler politique
certainement pourraient rêver qu'elle
soit aussi conçue par les habitants
mais en fait nos villes sont aujourd'hui
le produit du monde de la technique
et les villes qui expriment qui
construisent et qui transmettent
longtemps les valeurs et les aspirations
d'une société
aujourd'hui elle traduisent la dominance
la domination sans partage du monde
artificiel sur le monde de naturel
et cette domination elle est
omniprésente quand je voyage je suis
presque toujours accueilli dans une
chambre
réfrigérée l'été si c'est l'hiver et les
par contre surchauffé comme si le luxe
était d'être toujours à contre-saison
alors on a envie d'ouvrir la fenêtre
mais si on peut pas le faire on peut pas
le faire parce que justement il y a
l'air conditionné
et donc la fenêtre est condamnée c'est
la technique qui m'empêche qui dessine
que je ne vais pas pouvoir
profiter de la douceur du climat sentir
les l'odeur du du jardin en contrebas
écoutez les bruits de la ville en fait
c'est comme si j'habitais une cabine
dans une grande machine car la vie est
devenue une sorte de très grande
infrastructure
alors la technique elle est à l'origine
même de la ville qui s'est développée au
départ on oublie aujourd'hui puisque la
situation s'est inversée au départ la
ville elle se développe en fait contre
une nature hostile et imprévisible
n'oublions pas Descartes qui nous dit
l'homme doit se rendre maître et
possesseur de la nature quel programme
temps de Descartes
dans le monde il y a à peu près 500
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui nous
vivons dans une planète
urbaine de près de 8 milliards qu'il
faut loger je rappelle que la ville est
une chose formidable
elle arrive à contenir aujourd'hui
presque 60% de la population mondiale
dans moins de 3% du territoire
disponible
mais ce n'est pas pour autant que nous
ressentons la ville non plus comme une
cité mais comme une infrastructure
une infrastructure où nous nous sentons
plus tellement des sujets libres et
autonome mais bien des objets un monde
où certains d'entre nous vont passer
leur vie entière si on parle si on pense
aux grandes aux grandes métropoles
asiatiques et où ce sont leurs gestes
qui vont devoir s'adapter à des machines
un monde entièrement
artificiel avec cette impression d'être
même toujours contrôler toujours
transporté par l'infrastructure
et la production industrielle elle
n'arrête pas
de produire des nouveaux objets de
nouvelles technologies
qui nous envahissent qui envahissent
l'espace public et on a l'impression que
ça se production elle est comme
indépendante de notre volonté alors on
est un peu saturé chaque foyer français
possède en moyenne une centaine chez lui
d'objets électronique ou électrique des
objets qui sont de plus en plus
connectés et qui en plus vont nous
solliciter et cette tyrannie en quelque
sorte de l'innovation
il semble qu'il soit impossible de la
contester
Emmanuel Macron il y a deux ou trois ans
à Bible si vous êtes contre la 5G
éclairez-vous avec une lampe à huile on
voit que le débat est impossible quand
il s'agit de contredire l'idéologie du
progrès
cet homme Willys Carrier et certainement
celui qui a le plus influencé la ville
au 20e siècle
vous ne trouverez pourtant pas son nom
dans les livres d'architecture c'est
l'inventeur de la climatisation au
tournant du siècle en 1902
avec lui
l'air intérieur se sépare de l'air
extérieur l'air intérieur devient à
température constante hygrométrie
contrôlée pureté certifié mais en fait
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que l'air
intérieur devient à son tour
le produit de la technologie devient un
produit de consommation il n'est plus ce
milieu dans lequel toute l'humanité a
baigné de façon indifférenciée depuis la
nuit des temps
et avec cette invention le visage de nos
villes va profondément changer puisque
les espaces intérieurs étant autonome
les bâtiments vont s'affranchir du
climat du soleil du vent et on va
pouvoir produire le même environnement
urbain indifférencier dans toutes les
villes dans toutes les villes du monde
les architectes en fait ils ont
accompagné cette prise de pouvoir de la
technique ils ont été fascinés par le
travail des ingénieurs Le Corbusier dit
la maison c'est la machine à inviter
mais qui voudrait habiter
dans la cabine dans la 380 qui est
pourtant sorte d'habitacle technique
parfait
alors cette prédominance de la technique
dans la façon dont nous faire de ville
il faut évidemment la contester il faut
évidemment la remettre en question
d'abord
en raison des problèmes qu'elle causent
avec le climat
je ne vais pas développer ici parce que
je dirais que c'est presque une cause
entendue et vous êtes certainement
impliqué dans cette prise de conscience
mais aussi parce que cette ville
infrastructure au moment de la crise
sanitaire en fait elle a trahi la
confiance des habitants on pouvait
croire que la sophistication des villes
allait nous protéger c'est l'inverse qui
s'est produit c'est à dire que cette
sophistication technique a été la cause
même de la fragilité d'un réseau
mondialisé de grandes villes qui a été
stoppée net par les confinements
mais peut-être qu'en tant qu'architecte
en tant que défenseur d'une vie
humaniste ce que je trouve le plus
important
c'est la relation des habitants avec la
ville cette relation avec la technique
qui est devenue problématique
et qu'il faut changer il faut se servir
de cette prise de conscience du
développement durable pour au-delà des
ressources au-delà de la bonne gestion
de l'énergie penser la ville autrement
il faut établir un contrat entre
architecture nature et technique
ce contrat nous en avons esquisser une
une image avec le pavillon de la France
et le thème de la ville sensuelle à
Shanghai en 2010 pour l'exposition
universelle
nous avons mis le climat les habitants
au premier plan de la ville
évoquant dans une fresque vidéo
les la bonne relation que la ville peut
entretenir avec les saisons avec le
temps qui passe avec le jour avec la
nuit
montrant que
si on ne s'oppose pas aux éléments
si on
au contraire on est à l'unisson avec ces
éléments et bien ça peut être une source
de plaisir une source de désir de ville
d'une ville sensuelle
le bâtiment lui-même était construit
comme le prototype
d'une architecture qui fusionnait avec
le paysage un paysage où on pouvait se
promener l'usage on pouvait se reposer
et on ne pouvait pas dissocier nature et
construction un bâtiment qui est un îlot
de fraîcheur et de senteurs et alors ce
thème de la ville sensuelle ça a été un
incroyable succès puis qu'avec 10
millions de visiteurs en 6 mois
ça a été le bâtiment le plus visité de
l'Exposition universelle c'est pour ça
que nous avons continué avec mon associé
Pauline Marchetti à développer cette
idée avec un laboratoire où nous
partageons nos recherches par des
publications des rencontres et des
expositions
qui sont qui ont pris place ces
dernières années dans de nombreuses
villes dans le monde entier à Rouen nous
avons fait face à un défi technique
environnemental en construisant le plus
grand bâtiment public passiva ou en
France c'est-à-dire un bâtiment qui
chaque année consomme moins d'énergie
qui non produit mais l'image de ce
bâtiment c'est pas une machine
environnementale c'est en fait une
façade impressionniste
inspirez des séries de Claude Monet sur
le portail de la cathédrale de Rouen
justement où il montre que ce bâtiment
change de couleur à chaque heure de la
journée
et nous avons mis en place 2500 panneaux
photovoltaïques qui contribuent à
produire une partie de l'énergie du
bâtiment comme un tableau
impressionniste
ces panneaux sont revêtus de nos couches
décroïques qui fait que selon
l'incidence de la lumière il change de
couleur subtilement et le dispositif
environnemental devient la matière même
de l'architecture il devient un
dispositif poétique
pour ceux qui vivent dans le bâtiment
évidemment n'est pas climatisé
et ce bâtiment s'ouvre de partout
prolongeant les espaces de travail à
l'extérieur
utilisant les patios qui sont
nécessaires pour le refroidissement
naturel des espaces comme autant de
ponctuations des parcours à l'intérieur
des bureaux
et finalement accompagnant les nouvelles
façons de travailler par l'architecture
une façon de travailler ou quand on veut
on peut se sentir partie prenante du
paysage et du climat
alors aujourd'hui le défi constructif
aussi c'est de ne pas consommer de
territoires c'est de construire la ville
sur la ville c'est assez compliqué ici
c'est un grand bâtiment de bureau que
nous avons construit un briquet dans la
gare Montparnasse enfin tout compte mais
aussi au-dessus de ses locaux technique
une gare qui est une des plus
fréquentées d'Europe
et pourtant nous avons voulu contribuer
à amplifier l'espace public dans un des
quartiers les plus denses et les plus
congestionnés de Paris
et en fait au-delà de la construction ce
qui était important pour nous c'est de
créer un passage un lieu public ouvert
évidemment aux occupants du bureau mais
aussi à tous les parisiens à l'abri du
bruit à l'abri du trafic de la
circulation qui deviennent une pause
dans la journée et qui deviennent un
lieu de rencontre dans lequel ce sont
installés un café un restaurant une
fondation d'art contemporain un lieu
dans lequel on a fait entrer le ciel
avec une façade
qui évoque
qui veut que ce grand ciel qu'on voit si
peu à Paris et ce ciel qu'on partage
ensuite dans les étages qui sont tous
des terrasses accessibles où on peut
même trouver un jardin
cultivable qui produit des plantes
comestibles et dans lequel on peut avoir
des leçons de jardinage donc une façon
aussi de mieux être ensemble dans ce
lieu de travail
alors là
et où on peut installer des expositions
temporaires
à Shanghai toujours sur ce campus c'est
le rez-de-chaussée qui est un paysage
construit
et qui a même temps que la construction
la compense en quelque sorte en offrant
un havre de biodiversité et de fraîcheur
un paysage d'ailleurs que l'on peut
traverser pour aller du jardin à la rue
à côté
alors vous l'avez compris cette
cette vision d'une nature et d'une
architecture mêlée c'est toujours liée
aussi à l'espace collectif mais aussi à
la propriété
comme pour ces logements à Montpellier
ou pour
trouver là aussi de la fraîcheur nous
avons conçu un immeuble jardin et j'aime
bien ces photos qui montrent comment
cette décision de construction a permis
l'épanouissement
d'une appropriation de chacun des
jardins qui sont pieds d'immeubles des
jardins qui sont sur les balcons et de
faire de chacun
l'acteur de son logement l'acteur de son
quartier
tout est possible avec la technique tout
est possible à condition qu'on la mette
dans son rôle de moyens que de servante
elle devienne pas maîtresse mais qu'elle
soit au service d'une vision de la ville
cette vision de la ville il faut l'avoir
ensemble on ne peut pas nous seul
experts la définir aujourd'hui il faut
impliquer les habitants comme on le fait
ici sur le chantier du Grand Paris
Express
il faut que tous ensemble on trouve une
autre route une autre voie vers une
ville en résonance avec le climat
respectueuse de l'environnement
une ville en résonance avec le contexte
et donc ils prennent en compte les
cultures et les cultures aussi
constructives locales et surtout une
ville en résonance avec le corps des
habitants et là derrière la ville magie
nous pourrons retrouver la cité ouverte
à tous les vivants merci
[Applaudissements]